as we reported earlier allegations of
sexual misconduct are sending shock
waves through the national women's
soccer league former players sinead
fairley and monashem accused their
former coach his name is paul riley of
sexual harassment and coercion in just
one example farley says the coach
coerced her into having sex with him in
a team hotel room they also say that
riley sent them both unsolicited
explicit photos of himself now paul
riley denies all the accusations against
him shem filed an official complaint
with her team's management this was back
in 2015.
riley's contract was not renewed but he
was hired by another team just five
months later so he's still able to coach
since the allegations have been made
public riley has been fired from his job
with the north carolina courage and the
u.s soccer announced it suspended his
license to coach anywhere we spoke to
shimon farley earlier about their
experience
it's so hard to understand why this was
allowed to continue for so long why do
you think it has taken this long and why
was it allowed to go on for this long
so
big picture our institution failed us
the system right it's the people empower
not just the coach who abuse us
but the leadership team
that enabled him
and
allowed him to go coach elsewhere so i
think it was just a total lack of
leadership and accountability
and
they didn't care that's the important
point you made though just there in 2015
you were told it was investigated he was
let go it was let go but then months
later
a short time later he got another job
coaching
what did you think when you saw that i
was devastated the first thing of course
is concern for for other players that he
will coach and that's been
to me the most concerning thing
since this happened to me is who's next
but ultimately i just felt failed in
silence and
like nobody was looking out for us i
felt unsafe you know sinead you know
based on what i'm reading and hearing
coach riley did seem to be a master
manipulator can you speak to that
i was filled with fear every single day
because i felt
under the control of his manipulation
and
the lack of safety just makes it really
difficult to show up and
do my job and be who i am as a person so
it really really affected me
coach riley has denied the allegations
against him he said he has never forced
anyone to do anything inappropriate
sexually or otherwise he says that he
didn't have anything to do with
encouraging players to drink
um what do you say to that um
i just know that
that can be that statement alone can be
discounted by
if dozens if not more players and
um
i know my own truth and that's all i can
speak to
you say that after an encounter in a
hotel room he said we will take this to
our graves
that is something that has replayed in
my mind for
i mean
for 10 years and
that i was truly convinced
i was going to
i was going to do and follow and
take this to my grave
i'm sure it's no surprise to you that
he's denying the allegations what more
needs to be done and how prevalent is it
it's extremely prevalent and i want to
say that he's a liar and that's what
these men do
they the truth comes out about their
behavior and they lie to try and cover
it up and it's
it's so upsetting to know that they just
continue to do this
sinead you said that he changed you as a
player and as a person
what do you mean
soccer for me was my safe space in my in
my world and something that i had such
an innocent pure love for since i was
little girl
and that was taken from me
so it was just difficult to show up on
the field after that and have confidence
in myself
um
and
i used to be so free when i played and
i didn't feel like that anymore
um
and that directly really like seeped
into who i was as a person
the way that i saw myself
i didn't i didn't know at the time why i
couldn't show up the way that i wanted
to and why why soccer couldn't be what
it used to and
i turned this anger and rage that i had
towards him that i felt i didn't feel
validate the time to feel towards him
and i put it on myself yeah sinead what
would it help in your healing because
talking about it i know doesn't make it
go away it doesn't erase the memories
what would help in your healing and what
do you think needs to be done um
to disclose the story and not feel so
um
stuck in this secret and have to hold on
to this anymore is liberating in itself
yeah
and just the number of times that we
have to hear this story and talk about
it
we shouldn't have to do this over and
over and over again
but until they put the policies in place
until they take real action i'm telling
you these apologies are empty to me so
in my opinion every single person who
was a part of this who is a part of
covering this up who knew
they need to step down at the very least
be suspended by the leak for women who
are sitting here listening to you both
this morning what is your message to
them today
be brave
yeah of course we support you but also
we're working hard to prevent this from
happening we want we want an environment
a safe working environment for
professional soccer players college
soccer players youth soccer players that
is free of harassment and sexual
anything right
and that's our goal and we're trying our
best and thanks to you and others who
are allowing us to speak on this
now the league is vowing to in their
words undertake a significant systemic
and cultural transformation
to regain the trust of players and the
fans those initiatives include an
executive board led by three current
players a reopening of the 2015
investigation into paul riley in an
independent review of the
anti-harassment policies at all levels
of the organization and you know when
mana and and sinead hear that they just
think blah blah blah what are you really
going to do put out a statement and say
you know this isn't who we are we don't
tolerate that she said something very
interesting to me guys mana she said
it's so hard
and interesting to hold heartbreak and
outrage in the same space
and they've just simply had it they've
just simply they're tired of the stories
they're tired of this happening and they
said listen if somebody had done
something in 2015 and they believe more
women will come forward now that others
have spoken up somebody had paid
attention in 2015 maybe it wouldn't be
happening the way it is they believe
it's still happening even if the league
does everything it said it would what's
so agonizing is nothing's going to
change the past
sinead is going to always have that
experience memories of soccer and mana
as well but we can't change the future
that's for sure that's for sure